hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so you notice i
drew this kind of descending slope and
these are six different morally relevant
conditions or states of a person that
Arizona talks about in book seven the
Nicomachean ethics and the ones that he
doesn't talk about too much our super
human virtue virtue and vice and study
talks a lot about self-control lack of
self-control and then something that's
translated in some taxes as bestiality
but it's better to transfer the
brutality the greek word for it is 30
days which means to be like an animal so
to be reduced to the level of cheery
animality we are animals right but we're
rational animals and this the rational
part gets gets set aside so why does he
distinguish between all these because
they're they're different states and
they don't all have the same structure
they don't all behave in the same way
and you can arrange them and kind of
best to its worst now super human virtue
the reason he doesn't talk much about it
is he says first off it's really rare
and if you've got super human virtue
you're you're done you know you're
always going to do the right thing
you're beyond normal virtue he says it's
almost divine and so there's really not
much else to talk about that he's not a
theologian right virtue we've already
talked about good at it so we don't have
to go into that self-control and lack of
self-control here's where it gets really
interesting so the self-control person
will behave very much like the virtuous
person when they're called upon to do
the right thing they will generally do
the right thing but they won't do it
with the same kind of motivation as the
virtuous person the virtuous person part
of what makes them virtuous is they they
want now to do the right thing it feels
good to them to do the right thing so
let's let's say we take generosity on if
you know it's walking called liberality
and other translation but let's call it
generosity if you're generous and that's
part of your character you want to be
generous with other people you want to
give to the right people at the right
time for the right reason you will
probably give quite a bit of your your
stuff your excess guelph away glad you
know if you if you don't have a lot of
excess wealth you're not going to give
away all the stuff you have you're going
to have enough to keep yourself in house
and home and you know with all the tools
that you need for your work but then the
excess you'll find good good people to
give it to you won't just going to walk
up to anybody and give them a million
dollars you'll look for worthy causes
that's what it is to be generous and
you'll want to do things that way you'll
have a desire to be that way
to exercise that kind of activity now if
you have self-control but you're not yet
virtuous you will act like a generous
person when when it's the right
circumstances for that but you won't
really want to do you'll force yourself
to do it why because you recognize
that's the right thing so with with
self-control person reason where the
intellect is functioning the right way
but desire is telling them to do
something else and with generosity what
are what are the main desires that we
have the interfere with generosity yeah
you know we want to hold on to our stuff
it might not necessarily just be desired
to have our stuff to enjoy it it might
also be fear you no worries about you
know if I don't hold on to more if I
don't save all this then maybe all the
destitute or you know have to look to
other people for handouts you know what
yeah good like with that then we'll feel
like another way to look at like your
bike being generous you internal
you yeah you know you're Istanbul
doesn't have too much of a problem yeah
he thinks that friends at least are
going to be sharing things back and
forth but if you were doing if you're
being generous only to get the reward
then the eris level so you're not truly
being generous but you know that would
still be a better motivation and state
than just saying screw everybody I'm not
going to give anything to anybody and
that might be the self-control Russian
maybe they tell themselves yeah you know
it's the right thing to do and I really
feel like doing it but you know I will
get this out at least that other people
will give me things in return now if the
self control person keeps on doing what
they do there's a tendency for them to
become virtuous this is why it's very
important to to practice virtue because
you don't you know you're not naturally
virtuous you actually have to act like a
virtuous person before you become
virtuous input your ethics so the
self-control person is at least doing
the right thing they don't really feel
like doing it but they recognize what
the right thing to do is the person
there's a lack of self-control they also
recognize it the right thing to do is
Jeff there they have a properly
functionalism they also have a desire to
do something different but what do they
do they follow that desire and there's a
conflict within them there's I mean
there's a conflict with then the person
who has self control too isn't there
reason is in conflict with with desire
but with this person it's it's more of a
conflict because you can never really
count on them and they can't even truly
count on themselves to what they're
going to do in a situation they might do
the right thing sometimes and then not
do the
other times somebody who has a lack of
self-control let's say with respect to
food they know that they shouldn't have
that extra helping they know that you
know ice cream before going to bed while
watching TV is not the right thing to do
if they actually want to be healthy or
lose weight or pick whatever else you
want right somehow they find themselves
doing and they they oftentimes feel down
about that's one difference between the
person is a lack of self control of the
person who is vicious the person who is
vicious they think they're doing the
right thing they say yes ice cream
before bed that's exactly what I should
be doing as a matter of fact if you're
not doing it there's something wrong
with you and then when they see other
people having ice cream before bed they
say they're there it is there that
person has their head on straight and
when they all the people come up to them
and say you know you really shouldn't
have ice cream before you go to bed they
say you know things like who are you to
judge me or you don't know my situation
they you know they come up with officers
of self-defense things but really what
it comes down to is they want to be that
way the person who has a lack of
self-control they don't really want to
be that they're just unable to actually
make their rightly functioning reason
effective I think we've all experienced
this enemy one time at least with
respect to something so if we go even
further to brutality what's the
difference between that advice well with
Vice this part of reason is still in the
human being it's become corrupted
practically
there's something wrong with it that's
why the person has got the wrong general
ideas so the greedy person thinks that
everybody should be like Gordon Gekko
and his greed as good speech he's an
example of somebody who's vicious he
because he actually believes that he's
you know he's vicious with brutality or
you know descent to Sherry animality the
reasoning part of the person is either
so damaged or disengaged or just lacking
all together that they've been reduced
just to shear animality and unlike the
other animals that have instincts to
rely on when you remove reason for moths
which is what's really distinctive to
human beings we become the worst of the
animals we become capable of just about
anything and so you know if you ask
aristotle about cases where somebody's
doing horrific things sometimes it might
be because they're vicious but sometimes
it's because they're at the level of the
brutal the beast ship yeah I like people
that like do things for their culture
religion but they're the top of their
morals yeah that's so that's a good
question you know I've ever had a
student he actually asked me
and I've done this material the
Aristotle turkey here's the sort of
quick answer that Aristotle would say
well those people are barbarians and you
can't count on them to do the right
thing anyway because obviously they're
not Greeks so you know there any is
willing to say yeah I mean some people
are just brutal but I think if you SAT
eras level down and you said yeah okay
put aside all the Greek barbarian stuff
and now we actually want to hold you to
this make this theory really work and
you posed him that problem he would say
something along these lines you would
say that there are cultures in which the
understanding of right and wrong can be
become very deformed and it gets
transmitted through the culture so
generation and it puts people in
situations where they think that they're
recognizing the right thing but they're
actually recognizing the wrong so that
they're more like like the vicious now
when vice Aristotle says becomes goes to
its extremes then it actually starts to
slide into brutality the vicious person
Aristotle thinks is in a certain way
it's still responsible for their
viciousness if you were in the kind of
culture where you literally did not have
a shot you couldn't possibly think
otherwise then the waiting room
brainwashed into thinking with respect
moral issues should you tell people who
should you tell under what circumstances
that era Solomon said is more like like
brutality and it's interesting when it
comes to brutality Aristotle says it's
in certain ways less bad advice because
if the person is not as responsible for
their behavior they may not be
responsible at all you know when we're
talking about compulsion if you have
some sort of compulsion that you
actually did not resist whatsoever to
you know kill people horrible ways
you're you're not vicious you're brutal
and Aristotle would say well that person
is not actually morally responsible for
what they do on the other end says by
your brutality is more horrific than
vice why because there's something
fundamentally lacking in the human being
of them something that was human has
been sort of taken away from yeah so
would someone who is vicious be
conscious but then during
no at least not once they're like firmly
established advice they think that doing
the wrong thing is the right thing so
the greedy person thinks that everybody
should be greedy so without behavior oh
they yeah when it comes to the question
of ignorance and responsibility the
vicious person is ignorance of certain
sort of broad picture general presets
that's what it means for a reason to be
corrupted but they are responsible for
that Arizona things usually people get
to become vicious by doing the wrong
thing over and over and over again now
you know there's a question here that
you can ask is this culture thing brings
it up we're not all born into the same
cultural situations what if you're born
into say a family where everybody beats
everybody up old you know you're going
to have a really hard time
distinguishing with the right
disposition is with respect to angular
for one thing and probably also with
respect to courage we've probably got to
be more on the fool army side and the
other side eres level doesn't think that
we outside like a completely level
playing field
hold people responsible just suffice is
that they actually could have changed
now if you were in a culture where it's
so hard core that you couldn't possibly
do otherwise then he would say that's
more like brutality and again he thought
some of the people of his own time were
like that some of some of the foreigners
mean if you look at some of the things
that some of the Greeks to each other he
uses something there's a guy phalaris
and he made this giant bowl and it was
it was you know just the right size to
put a human being inside and then you
put a fire under the bowl and the whole
thing would heat up and the screams of
the the people inside would go through
this system of pipes and come out
sounding like you know a little like
like music you got to be kind of a
twisted person to think that that's the
right thing to do but that makes sense
don't you so that level of stuff he
thinks is what we call brutality and he
gives you a few examples besides it he's
you know he says how do we acquire this
sometimes it's through disease you know
something goes wrong with the brain I
think we would say or he actually brings
up insanity can happen through habits
and it's interesting because he points
out among the habits that can generate
this those who have been abused you know
severe abuse can in certain ways rob
people of something that's distinctively
human and reduce them to sheer animality
now is it is that their fault though I
mean they've been just something as
active a ton but they do terrible things
don't they things that we want to
protect
other people from he says sometimes it
has to do with natural disposition you
know somebody's development could be
arrested you know there's discussions
about for instance sociopaths and
whether their brain activity is
different than other people sociopaths
are people who lack a sense of
conscience so to speak so there are some
would say they're lacking that right be
functional reason and they're beyond
Vice they would do what about addiction
you know at a certain point perhaps you
could say that very hard for addictions
could land somebody in this category to
the bedroom certainly you know if it's
something that doesn't have organic
damage to the brain to where they don't
think what the alcohol for example if
you really drink a lot of alcohol you're
burning through brain cells and
eventually start affecting major areas
of the brain and a certain point you
can't control what you're doing you know
before that you know you might just hit
lack of self-control vicious but at a
certain point you do enough damage to
your brain you don't you're there's no
longer really you in the moral sense to
make those decisions there's just
alcohol and alcoholism driving
everything yeah is that over like a long
or can also be just drink a lot about 51
well I mean this is a scientific
question I I I don't think that there
are cases where somebody just gets
dropped once brings a ton of alcohol so
addicted to alcohol I think some drugs
might be more addictive hi al I may have
mentioned a family member of mine to try
beaubien ones who said he would never
try it again the reason he would never
try it again is because it was he felt
it was so pleasurable that if you were
to try it again he knew he'd be [ __ ]
so what was he doing from an
Aristotelian perspective he was actually
being very prudent he was recognizing
his own you know likely lack of
self-control with that the fact that he
would slide it to the vice of lack of
moderation in temperatures with respect
to that that physical pleasure and so he
cut that off the pastor said I'm never
doing that again what's smart move yeah
but what is it truly like Richard
bycicle why
in fact that something addictive he
probably shouldn't try yeah wise person
wouldn't wouldn't mess with those sorts
of games you know when it comes to the
virtue of there are some things that you
can have a right amount of you could
have a right amount of alcohol for
instance right amount is not so much
that you're falling down drunk but it
might be the you know the right amount
for the occasion which is to have a good
time with some friends right and you
actually have certain point consign no
no I'm not going to have another there
are some things where no amount of is a
good amount I think you know Aristotle
if you were to talk about temperance and
you already asked him about a heroin
crack cocaine or PCP or math then you
ever say well what's the right amount
I'm going to go to a party I want to be
a virtuous person at least self control
how much death can I have I think Aris
level say you can't have any because
once you start with that stuff it's such
a so attentive than such a steady
decline you couldn't you couldn't make
it he says that about some other things
like for instance adultery he says you
can't ask well how much should I be
adulterous what would be the virtuous
mean how much cheating at my spouse is
acceptable or would be would make me a
good person he says none of it you can't
have any of that how many people can I
at person you know if you're if you're
killing people you're a murderer and
that's already off the scale so there
are certain things like good question